even though controllers sport is better
than ever in PC gaming there's still
some games to either need or straight-up
better with a keyboard and mouse but
what if you want to play on a couch or
in a home theater setup instead of at a
desk there are a couple solutions out
there but nothing quite like the combo
of Corsairs new lap board and k63
wireless mechanical keyboard
[Music]
this isn't Coursera's first attempt at a
lap board they also have the lap dog
which is wired and uses an external
power source to work properly it was a
bit bulky and heavy and was an ideal in
certain situations especially compared
to the new case 63 lap board now we have
something that's light compact and
Wireless that doesn't sacrifice the
quality we come to expect from high-end
gaming keyboards first let's cover the
case 63 keyboard it sports a 10 keyless
design which means it ditches the number
pad for a smaller footprint but it still
has super useful dedicated media keys
this keyboard only comes with cherry MX
red mechanical switches and lucky for me
it's my favorite switch type but you'd
be out of luck if you're not into the
smooth linear non tactile keystrokes
blue is also your only color option when
it comes to LED backlighting since this
is wireless battery life is a big
question
thankfully the case 63 holds plenty of
juice and its built-in USB charge
battery we spent about eight hours in
total using the K 63 and not once did we
have to worry about charging it up
granted we set the backlight brightness
to the lower preset most of the time
Corsair states that on a full charge the
case 63 lasts up to fifteen hours at
full brightness 25 hours on low
brightness and 75 hours without
backlighting this keyboard connects
wirelessly through the 2.4 gigahertz USB
dongle that is set to offer one
millisecond response time and it can
connect through Bluetooth the package
includes a palm rest with a rubbery
silicon texture that snaps to the bottom
this is also how you snap the k63
into the lap board attachment which is
the real reason why we're here it fits
into the lap board effortlessly and two
latches help keep the keyboard secured
you should note that the K 63 is the
only keyboard that fits into this lap
board as for the design of the lap board
itself there are rubbery silicon
textures at the palm area but aren't
quite positioned right
my palm tends to rest the top of plastic
parts but it's not much of a problem a
cloth mousepad is built into the lap
board and offers slick and accurate
tracking I wouldn't replace his surface
since I much prefer cloth mouse pads but
if you want to use your own surface you
can since it'll grip onto the lap board
easily in stay in place for those that
are used to larger Mouse surfaces you
may need to adjust to the smaller size
here of course comfort is one of the
more important aspects and it is not
overlooked in the lap boards design
there's a dense memory foam at the
bottom and it makes it comfortable to
have on your lap for long sessions and
thankfully this thing isn't very heavy
at about five and a half pounds an
important thing to note is that there
aren't any USB pass-through ports on the
case 63 or the lap board so you'll
definitely need to pick up a good
wireless mouse to get the most out of
the setup going with the setup isn't
gonna come cheap though the k63 itself
cost 110 bucks and the lap board goes
460 but you can buy these together for a
hundred and sixty and save yourself ten
bucks and as mentioned previously if you
don't have a wireless mouse you'll have
to factor in the cost of that as well
it's the price you pay for quality and
convenience overall Corsair is on point
with this pairing the k63 itself is a
great mechanical keyboard on its own and
it's wireless to boot with cherry MX red
switches and dedicated media keys I
couldn't be happier with the 10 keyless
design and when you pair it with an
expertly designed lap board you get the
best solution for PC gaming on a couch
or home theater without resorting to a
gamepad if you're willing to shell out
the dough we're continuing to cover the
latest in PC peripherals so stick the
GameSpot for all that good stuff thanks
for watching
you